نقلت صحيفه معريف عن نائب رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي السابق يائير جولان قوله ان
المشكله الاساسيه في العمليه البريه هي ان
المستوى السياسي لا يوضح ما هي اهداف
الحرب مطالبا القياده السياسيه بقول
الحقيقه لشعبها وتاخير القضاء على حماس
واضاف انه لا مفر من التوصل الى اتفاق مع
حماس وليس مع اي فاعل اخر لانها الوحيده
القادره على اطلاق سراح المختطفين
واوضح ان حماس دخلت الحرب مدركه ان
سيناريو تدمير الضاحيه الجنوبيه محتمل
ولفت جولان الى ان حماس حققت هدفا
استراتيجيا حين قالت لاسرائيل انها هي من
يدير الصراع واكد ان النهجه الحاليه من
الكذب يعني ان الاسرائيليين لن يعودوا الى
ديارهم على الحدود وسيستمرون بالعيش في
بلد
مهدد